on this friday night continued questions
about the astrazeneca shot
am i a second-class vaccinated person
by having two doses of astrazeneca plus
the plans to have enough
mrna doses to vaccinate every canadian
twice
by the end of july a white canadian
police officer
kneeling on the neck of a black teenager
the demands for an investigation
the western u.s in the midst of a
searing heat wave
it's scary it really is the ingredients
for what's expected to be another
intense wildfire season
and party on or off it's a real insult
to indigenous people
the debate over canceling canada day
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
another sign tonight canada is on track
for a two dose summer
if all goes as planned there will be
more than enough covid19 doses in the
country to vaccinate
every eligible canadian by the end of
july
5 million more moderna doses are now
expected by the end of june that's in
addition
to 9.1 million doses coming from pfizer
in the coming weeks that means by the
end of july
68 million doses are expected enough to
give two doses to all
32 million eligible canadians and public
health officials are trying to clarify
the
changing advice about the astrazeneca
vaccine it's not that provinces must
stop
giving people astrazeneca as their
second dose people can still get it and
know they'll be protected from serious
illness and death
but the national advisory committee on
immunization says the preferred
second dose now is pfizer or moderna
because
they offer a slightly higher immune
response and there's more of it in the
country
nearly 2.9 million doses of the
astrazeneca vaccine have been
administered so far
that's according to the covid 19 tracker
canada
many people have already had both doses
others
are still waiting for their second in
our top story tonight
mike lacatura looks at what they need to
know
am i a second class vaccinated person
by having two doses of astrazeneca sam
glass
isn't second guessing taking a second
dose of astrazeneca
but as someone who loves to travel he
worries what might
happen once he ventures outside of
canada where astrazeneca
has yet to be approved the concern is if
i show up at the american border
with you know being fully vaccinated
with astrazeneca will they accept me
further complicating things the national
advisory committee on immunization
is now saying an mrna vaccine is
preferred
for both your first and second shot but
just two months ago canadians were told
not to go vaccine shopping but rather
take the first one offered to them
people
may be asking questions or feel
frustrated a candidate's top doctor says
the science and the situation has
evolved pointing out getting any vaccine
was more important at the height of the
pandemic now you have less covid in our
country
and so the risk benefit ratio for the
even rare events start swinging in a
different way
with more mrna vaccines coming into
canada people will have a choice to mix
or continue with astrazeneca asked what
he is going to do
prime minister justin trudeau said i
will take whichever dose
is offered to me i will do what all
canadians should do which is
follow the best advice of the experts
around them including
nasty and their family doctors but some
doctors feel nasty's advice on
astrazeneca
could have been clearer when nasty
issues these statements
i would love for them to you know prior
to issuing them
actually deliberate a little bit more
with family doctors and pharmacists
and members of the public around you
know how that statement
might be received canada still has a
contract for another 17 and a half
million doses of the astrozenica vaccine
as for what will happen to
any unused doses procurement minister
anita anand reiterated canada's
commitment
to donate 100 million doses to other
countries in need
donna all right michael couture in
ottawa thanks
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine has been
approved for use in multiple countries
it does carry an increased risk of rare
blood clots in some people and because
of that some countries
suspended its use but there is no
question it has prevented serious
illness and death including in the uk
where millions of people have received
astrazeneca
for both doses as crystal gamansing
explains as more data comes in
public health experts need to keep
adjusting their advice
the pandemic has seen scientists working
at breakneck
speeds the constant stream of
information however
can lead to feelings of whiplash or
worse says dr
isaac bogash some people feel that you
know
they might have got a second class
vaccine i think it's fair to say that
that's
not really accurate in fact this week
public health england shared data
showing
two shots of astrazeneca offered 92
percent protection
against hospitalization when looking
specifically at the delta variant
astrazeneca has been a pillar of the
uk's vaccination campaign
the nhs has delivered this vaccination
program at record speed
it has been a fast and relatively smooth
process
but like every other country there have
been changes along the way
18 year olds who are now being offered
vaccines in
england will be given either pfizer or
moderna
a precautionary move following reports
of rare but serious blood clots
in australia officials raised the age to
60 and above for astrazeneca
the health minister noting it's
different everywhere
over 40 in the uk over 30 in south korea
no age limits within the prescribed
range
in germany whatsoever the european
medicines agency on thursday
said that more data has been made
available about the benefits of mixing
vaccines and countries
may choose again to alter their plants
it is well known that mixing and
matching vaccine often
ends up in a better immune response
but people should feel confident that
all of the approved covid19 vaccines are
safe and offer protection against
serious illness
crystal gomanson global news london
the restrictions at the canada u.s
border were extended again today
non-essential travel is restricted until
july 21st though prime minister justin
trudeau says there is an
interim plan being made to allow fully
vaccinated people to travel
internationally first of all
in the initial uh phase we're going to
be working
uh with the arrive can app in ways that
people can upload
an image of their paper proof of
vaccination or
online proof of vaccination so that the
border agents on their return to canada
can verify indeed that they are fully
vaccinated
the prime minister says discussions are
also underway with the provinces which
are responsible for health records
to develop a national certification
system that will be recognized
internationally
more details are expected on monday
we're seeing in different parts of the
country that sort of the
rate of vaccination for first doses is
is starting to uh
slightly plateau and certainly not at
the same as sort of accelerated pace as
it was earlier
that frank assessment is from canada's
deputy public health officer
vaccine uptake is leveling off in canada
even though about a quarter of eligible
people have not received their first
dose yet
eric sorenson looks at why and the
problem it could present for the months
ahead
canadians who got their first vaccines
are flocking to get a second
it's important because we want to get
this virus under control and we want to
go back to the way things were
but this remarkable scene of eager
second dosers
obscures an emerging trend first timers
are dropping off
recently canada surged ahead of most
countries almost 66 percent of canadians
have received their first shot
but the curve is beginning to flatten in
the last 10 days
3.6 of canadians received a first dose
in the previous 10 days it was 6.8
we're seeing in different parts of the
country that uh sort of the
rate of vaccination for first doses is
starting to uh
slightly plateau it was bound to happen
as canadians who are vaccine hesitant
make up a larger percentage of those who
remain unvaccinated
the concern is that covet variants will
require an even higher percentage of
canadians to be vaccinated
we're dealing with variants of concern
now that are more transmissible which is
going to push
uh you know that potential herd immunity
threshold higher but we have to get
greater uptake
and and that unfortunately is where
we're starting to falter the latest
survey by ipsos found high vaccine
willingness
82 percent of canadians are vaccinated
or interested in getting vaccinated
18 are hesitant about half of that group
is unsure
the other half a definite no the last
part of a vaccine
campaign is is the hardest if the
variant takes hold and we don't have
high enough vaccine coverage
what you will see is probably a
resurgence in the full period
alberta and manitoba are now offering
lottery incentives and other prizes to
coax people to get their shots
one bioethicist suggests a life-saving
vaccine
should be incentive enough but the
prizes are for a good cause
we have to play to win um and unless
it's an unreasonable interference on a
person's autonomy
if that nudge even represents a couple
of percentage or
i me i doubt it does but even as much as
five percent
i would say it's highly justifiable
public health officials are now looking
at other strategies
instead of inviting canadians to mass
vaccination clinics
they may turn to smaller outreach
programs for the last 20 percent or so
who cannot or will not go to clinics
eric sorensen global news toronto
alberta has reached a significant
covid19 vaccine milestone
just over 70 percent of eligible
albertans have received at least one
dose
and premier jason kenney says virtually
all remaining public health restrictions
will be lifted
on july first we'll get back to doing
the things that we all love
the things that make summer and alberta
so special
the province is also ramping up its
delivery of second doses anyone who
received their first
mrna shot in may or earlier can now book
their second
well more than 20 percent of ontarians
have now had both vaccine doses one of
the benchmarks for loosening
restrictions there
while overall there has been a decrease
in cases in ontario one region has
exploded
into a covet hotspot the highly
transmissible delta variant is spreading
in waterloo
and as jamie morocco reports the region
is at risk of going back
into lockdown keeping your distance yeah
for these waterloo ontario residents
masks are a must as cases of covid 19 in
the region continue to climb
we needed to stay down and people need
to get their second shots along with the
first shot but double doses have been
hard to come by in the community
leaving the door wide open for the
highly transmissible
delta variant to take over this week
waterloo topped the charts for the most
new coveted cases in the province
60 on friday alone what happens with
with these variants is that if you're
not careful then they
they can actually travel from one place
to another in the case of waterloo
experts believe this strain of the virus
may have been transmitted from an
outbreak at the baffin land mines in
nunavut as well as other forms of
community spread
close contact remains the most common
driver of transmission
the delta variant now makes up 65
percent of the covet 19 cases in the
waterloo region
it's a trend the world health
organization warned of as this becomes
the
dominant strain globally now experts say
vaccines particularly second doses are
the only way to get it under control
we're in an emergency this is a
situation where the delta variant
running rampant in community can make a
lot of people sick and we don't have
everybody with their two doses of the
vaccine politicians and doctors have
been asking the provincial government to
send more doses to the now hot spot
the ministry of health says 44 thousand
additional vaccines
are on the way back in waterloo chloe
tinsley says she had to wait
weeks to get an appointment for her
first shot i actually found
the vaccine access very frustrating now
with her first dose of pfizer behind her
she hopes she and others can ramp up
their protection and get a second dose
sooner
rather than later jamie morocco global
news toronto
another statue of canada's first prime
minister sir john a macdonald has been
removed this one from a park in what's
widely considered
his hometown of kingston ontario
it happened early this morning a crowd
gathered to watch
kingston city council voted to remove
the statue because of mcdonald's role as
an architect
of the indigenous residential school
system and because of the discovery of
what are believed to be the graves of
215 children
at the former kamloops residential
school the statue had been in place
since
1895 there are plans to relocate it to
the local cemetery where mcdonald
is buried canada's racist past has some
people wondering if
canada day should be cancelled the
debate coming up
plus outrage after a montreal police
officer kneels on the neck of a black
teenager
there is relief in the white shell
region of manitoba tonight where police
were searching for a murder suspect
the four-day manhunt ended early this
morning at a house in belleville ontario
the suspect and another man eventually
surrendered peacefully
after a tense standoff ontario
provincial police say they were shot at
while they moved in to arrest
34-year-old eric wildman
police warned he was armed and dangerous
he was wanted in the disappearance and
suspected homicide of his neighbor
40-year-old clifford joseph
upon entering they were met with gunfire
coming from within the residence
after lengthy negotiations the opp
crisis negotiators were able to
successfully
have these two men surrendered to police
the second man has been released police
surrounded the belleville home after
being tipped off about a vehicle
matching a rental car wildman was
driving
the manhunt started after police say
they found firearms ammunition police
patches and clothing resembling officers
uniforms
in wildman's truck on sunday he's been
charged with a firearms offense and
possessing a prohibited device
rcmp says search is underway on his
property and that more charges
are expected there is outrage and calls
for an investigation after a montreal
police officer was filmed kneeling on
the neck of a black teenager
and a warning the video is disturbing
[Music]
a bystander took this video in
montreal's villarreal district on june
10th
it is not clear what happened in the
moments before or exactly how long the
white officer had his knee on the teen
montreal police say they received a
9-1-1 call about a fight at a nearby
high school
the teen's mother says the incident has
reignited the trauma they felt after
george
floyd's death in minneapolis last year
and i asked one of the police officers
is it because my son is black that he
has to go through this they did not
learn anything
montreal police say they are analyzing
whether the officer's
use of force in the arrest was justified
a heat dome and a mega drought still
ahead the climate crisis bearing down
on the western u.s
[Music]
there is a searing heat wave in the u.s
and about 40 million americans are
caught
in it extreme weather events are
becoming more frequent and lasting
longer and climate scientists say it's
happening faster than they predicted
at least a dozen states faced another
day of sweltering temperatures above 38
degrees celsius
it was 43 degrees in las vegas
california's palm springs hit
a high of 46 so did phoenix arizona
as jackson proskow reports the heat is
fueling concerns
about an explosive wildfire season
it's already mid-summer hot before the
season has officially started
it's been pretty pretty hot nonstop
filling up the water
going in the pool for millions of
americans temperatures have soared from
the uncomfortable to the unbearable
this season this summer is honestly to
be one of the worst i've ever
experienced in california's death valley
the mercury approached
50 degrees celsius in arizona doctors
have warned that touching a sun-baked
doorknob
or car handle could cause severe burns
anyone in the city who's working
outdoors not in a climate-controlled
environment is absolutely at risk
for heat stroke or heat exhaustion that
over there used to be islands
the extreme heat comes at a time of
severe drought
california's lake mendocino has become a
desert
a problem because the water is an
important source for firefighting planes
and helicopters to air drop
we need water to survive and it's scary
it really is
firefighters are already training for
what's expected to be another
record-setting fire season they're
practicing their craft in these extreme
conditions
they work 24-hour shifts so it is
imperative for them to be acclimated to
this scientists see something more
alarming than just another heat wave
they warn this is the consequence of
climate change
these heat waves are going to be more
common more intense and more devastating
already residents in california and
texas have been warned the power
grid is at its limits they've been told
to conserve or face potential blackouts
this western state heat dome is a
dramatic reminder
that mother nature bats last and she
bats a thousand a preview
of what could be a long hot summer
jackson prosko global news
washington
meanwhile in canada watch this cool move
with a cookie and a glass of milk
that's winnipeg born cfl player shy ross
doing a perfect dunk midair
the edmonton elks receiver oh nice says
he grew up surrounded by gymnasts and
this trick he claims took five or ten
tries to get right
not that he's showing off or anything
we're backing him up
canada day is coming up and this year
there's a different feeling
there is much in this great country to
celebrate but
much that needs fixing and there are
growing calls to cancel traditional
canada day celebrations many saying now
just isn't the time as robin gill
reports depending on where you live the
party may or may not
go on
it's been almost two years since a big
canada day event
like this the city of calgary wants to
bring it back
in a safe way as much as we are
grappling with
difficult pieces of history there is a
lot to celebrate
the hashtag cancel canada day is making
its rounds on social media sites
it began when the capital of british
columbia decided to put a pause on the
party
after consulting with first nations
groups in the victoria area
we really began to understand
that they were in a place of mourning
and reflection
and that having them participate in a
very celebratory event just
just didn't feel right the discovery of
what's believed to be remains at the
site of the former kamloops residential
school
has fueled calls to rethink the annual
event
but july 1st has always been
controversial for its colonial roots
well it's a real insult to indigenous
people because it's a celebration of our
genocide
here in vancouver canada day
celebrations normally happen
right here at canada place but the port
which puts on the party
is reconsidering its plan even the idea
of a virtual party
a virtual event will go on in canada's
largest city
toronto is also building a spiritual
garden at city hall to honor survivors
of the residential school system
i would hope that part of what takes
place that day
in addition to celebrating this great
country that we're so fortunate to live
in will be
some time of reflection on us these
issues that have confronted us for a
long time with respect to the treatment
of our indigenous people
in the maritimes muted plans are moving
ahead
but despite the preparations there's an
understanding about the need for
reconciliation
the tragedy of the 215 children
in bc has certainly put a somber
perspective on being canadian if
anything this july first may be a time
to reflect on the many challenges
on so many fronts robin gill global news
vancouver
that is global national for this friday
i'm donna friesen tonight's here canada
is bellevue newfoundland and labrador
we'd love to see your canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching rob and gil will be
here at the anchor desk over the weekend
and i'll see you again on monday take
care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]